as much as we respect it if I'm his  coaches and team I just saw hey dude  forget this Gentleman's Agreement let's  let's have Wonder Boy thinking we're  going to take him down it's going to  only open up the Striking more which is  what you want to do and also when you  get him down if the submissions there go  for it man we need wins like you need  wins especially in the welterweight  division you need wins because that  Gentleman's Agreement doesn't pay your  mortgage that Gentleman's Agreement  doesn't extend your contract in the UFC  The Dana whites of the world and the the  Nick Maynards who do the uh you know  matchmaking don't care about a  gentleman's agreement